I had to get my boss a Lacroix like at
certain hours of the day but they didn't
tell me when they needed the lowboy so I
was just walking around with Lacroix
[Music]
hello interwebs
I am a keys hi I'm Rachel and we are
former Hollywood assistants and we're
gonna play never have I ever
luckily its former so we can't get fired
let's do the damn thing never have I
ever thought about quitting multiple
times a week every day look I literally
want to quit that job every single day
my current best friend I have because we
endured that awful job so that was the
one Pro that and I learned how to use
the printer I actually like the job
which is probably like a psychological
thing of like medias or something
goodbye I think that times in which I
wanted to quit is is the times in which
I get disrespected okay I don't really
mind doing something for other people I
don't really care but like when
someone's mean to me it makes me like
why would I want to help you and never
have I ever had a panic attack because
of work oh my therapy bill went through
the roof I have I think a lot of times
when I would have packetized prison was
like I was overwhelmed or it in like how
much together I never feel like I was
ever like oh my god this job is
absolutely awful I cannot do it because
I might be if the person sucked that bad
it was basically like being Andy and The
Devil Wears Prada but I didn't get the
Gucci you're no Miranda Priestly never
have I ever done something illegal for
my boss
I can say I haven't I have not done
anything illegal illegal I don't think
so I think it has to do weird crap and
I've quit because of it yeah never have
I ever used my own money for work oh yes
which is crazy
I remember they wouldn't give me a
corporate card for my first job because
they didn't have credit yet and so I
kept having to put
on my debit card but I didn't have any
money and then I was stuck in Boston and
didn't have money in my account to get
home for a work event because that guy
dispensed it on a hotel I had to call my
friend and ask her like wire me money it
was like really embarrassing yeah yeah I
have like uber lunches coffee's yep I
got the money back you know so awkward
bring it up oh no I only got that money
back I'm not giving yellow cent never
have I ever gotten fired and immediately
rehired I could say I have not tea one
of my first bosses and I were like best
friends
he was like an older brother for me I
don't think he was ever like your fire
but he was like Rachel I just don't know
if this is working out and I was so
crushed I mean like it felt like my like
it was like my first heartbreak yeah and
then like I think the next day we talked
and he was like hey I'm sorry but like
this is and it was like going favorite
relationship it was going through it
like I still think about him like he's
such AI just like wish him the best but
like he was like sometimes he got sour
very weird never have I ever been under
the influence at work this anxiety
medication cap this is before BuzzFeed
[Laughter]
consistently I have been hungover at
work before oh yeah 100% there
definitely been times where like you
have a day of Aaron's mom sudden you
have a martini hmm and you sit at the
bar drinking martinis so yeah I've
definitely done that never have I ever
rage quit I quit one of my jobs like
Thursday at like 10:30 at night because
it was like a lot of promises being made
of like trajectory in my career and it
wasn't happening and it was like I went
to work happy hour basically was told
from other people wasn't happening it
was like cool I'm out and I loved never
have I ever cried at work yep
yeah never have I ever been asked to do
something in the middle of the night
super early
morning yes 3 a.m. for him every hour
every day of the week weekends holidays
Christmas New Year's Christmas never
have I ever had family or friends
express their concern for my well-being
because of work
poor encouraged me to quit I'm mad I
picked this one up oh yeah I have my dad
was like you're not getting paid enough
to do the work that they're asking of
you as Drake said know yourself know
your worth there you go
it's the motto for today um the motto
also by Drake Wow I have had
relationships end because of my job more
than one very consistently throughout my
life my career comes first but I also
think having this job has really helped
me mentally not lose my mind in other
places never have I ever worked more
than 12 hours in a day I worked more
than 12 hours every day I slept in my
job so much and I was like I should
sublet my apartment yeah I remember my
dad was in town and he came to visit me
I hadn't seen my father in like a few
months yeah and I was scared to even ask
my boss for the day off even though I
have the career time you would think
that I like taking the day off means
like I don't have to be plugged in no I
had the day off but like I'm a beast
about twelve words my father I was
working at like 2:30 in the morning on a
Saturday and I would I mean like I'm
just gonna be honest I was drunk and I
remember I had to change a flight and
you have a car pick up and I was like I
hope this works
yes it's also like am I never gonna be
dealing in yeah anything else all right
never have I've never been told I was
doing a bad job by my boss oh yeah I
have but it was like you're just like
not operating at the capacity that I
want you to operate at and then that was
it no I'm doing great you're doing great
and then all of a sudden she's like
actually like you're not doing that
great sorry I didn't get your your
Lacroix Sondheim there have been times
where I've been working with someone
tried my best and they're like hey this
isn't working and I'm like this is how I
do it so like I don't know like we're
not working then honestly the only
reason why Hollywood is even running
right now the only reason I can even do
my current job is cuz of y'all
assistants out there so if you are an
assistant bless you if you're not an
assistant and you work with them have
some patience because like they're going
through a lot of and they're dealing
with a lot of like sorry if they took
seven minutes to respond to your email
rather than five
no they're assisting another person but
this person is still a person and like
be respectful you always want the
assistant on your side like it doesn't
and I will get to your email last if
you're a jerk it doesn't matter there
have been so many times where people are
nice to me and they'll have a problem
with something else and I'm like I know
how to do that like the back of my hands
I can help you and also for the people
who are assistants just like stay
patient try to have the best
relationship with your boss and if
they're toxic leave its you're not more
cool treat others how you want to be
treated I'm pretty sure Drake said that
[Music]